I I want to come back to something yeah
because this this is this is the stuff
that really drives me up a wall and it's
this
idea of people talking about what should
be and what it shouldn't be and we live
in a world where should and should not
doesn't matter the only thing that
matters is what is and what is not and
so saying well men should not be
attracted to women or men should not
pick women to date and be led by their
biological instinct which is physical
and sexual attraction as a primary not
the only but as the primary and if we
turn the shoe and put it on the other
foot then we're turning around telling
women well you should not be screening
for tall attractive handsome in good
shape men that have the ability to go
and make money and provide and protect
for me and my future children which is a
biological Instinct and a biological
drive when it comes to mate selection so
instead of saying this is the way humans
operate and have operated for Millennia
and we still operate today so take these
facts and take these tools to make the
best decision possible we're trying to
sit here and tell them not we but there
are people that are telling them that
doesn't matter that's old order thinking
we're not cavemen anymore this isn't the
50s blah blah blah women have rights
women can get credit cards this that and
the other and all that does is lie to
people all that does is lie to men and
tell them you can just be yourself and
women will just fall at your feet that
lies to women and say you can just let
yourself go and drink and party and do
drugs throughout your entire 20s or go
chase the bag until you're 35 or 40 and
then men are just going to fall and kiss
the feet you walk on and that's not the
reality for men and women today so why
do we continue to perpetrate this
nonsense just because we don't like the
way something sounds and it hurts our
feelings this is the stuff that drive
this this is the stuff that really
drives me crazy and it's the reason why
we do this show in the first place
because we want to have open and honest
conversations and we don't Pander to the
emotions of men or women and tell them
that the sun is always shining when it's
not and that water isn't wet and the sky
isn't blue we're here to deal with facts
and what is not what should
be is that a question no but but my
point is you seem to have an issue when
we say things like the primary
attraction driver for men is Beauty and
physical attraction I didn't have a
problem with that I had a problem with
the way that no I had an issue with the
way that tweet was presented as that was
the only thing I knew about rich up
until that point I don't have a problem
with saying that listen the whole reason
you guys brought me here and the whole
Reas went the whole reason that picture
went you know people were commenting on
it again was because of the way I look
whether you like it or you don't that's
that's why it was there I'm not going to
stand here and be like people don't care
about how you look of course they do and
yes what is the problem because I've
asked this qu we've asked this like
three or four times now and we're trying
to get to the Crux of what the issue is
and all we got all we're getting is tap
dancing
oversimplification of this to basically
throw every single person into this this
is it this is your value as a human
being as a as a woman your value is
diminished at 23 I don't agree that's
not what that's not what we ever said a
lot of women fting you're conflating
human value and sexual Marketplace value
when we're talking about value we're
talking about value to the opposite
sex I married a man that is this time
around I married a man who is nine years
my junior so and I married I met him in
my 30s you guys are saying something in
a g you married a guy nine years younger
yeah I did did he have any kids no and
he he doesn't have any children he does
not want children no so he's 9 years
younger and he adopted your four kids as
his own he did not adopt them they have
their father well I mean he plays a role
as stepdad I mean I'm I'm assuming the
most amazing se de yes yeah yeah yeah
wow I so my point is you are saying dos
are starting to
connect is it are you guys unplugging
and seeing the code in The Matrix I want
you to finish that
thought which sure you just said the
problem that my problem was the
generalization of it I think that
that why are generalizations an issue
just because you're the exception
generalizations now go out the window no
I think that it's a horrible
generalization don't prove a rule though
Martha they don't but here you are
sending a message Rich you have a
following of you have a pretty large
following of men you've seen how a lot
of these men these men that follow
yourself and your Tate like there's this
type of following of men who love to
talk [__] about women who love to to put
them down and do these things so you are
setting those aren't my boys those
aren't my
boys those are those are people that
have issues with women my boys all of my
boys Martha they're in long-term
relationships over a very long period of
time they lead the frame of the
relationship the woman's feminine she's
a compliment to his life they don't
fight comments along the side so I don't
know that those aren't your boys the
thing is there are plenty of men who are
wonderful I'm sure lovely gentlemen but
a large majority of them are not and so
when you say these things and you
Empower them to say it to so you want me
to lie to them then like what would you
like I don't want you to lie to them but
what was the point of that comment to
tell women that they hit a
wall accomplish okay you've got hundreds
of people watching you right now and you
think that I'm leading them wrong
because of the comments or whatever
their impression is why don't you speak
to them and tell them what it is that
you think they should be doing
better I think that men your speeech my
speech
sure what do I get wrong that that you
recommend that they do that would make
them better that would get them better
results out of
life that would get okay now you switch
it on something that they could do
better that would get them better
results start focusing on the what want
out of a woman does if you just want a
beauty queen then that's what you're
gonna get you're gonna get somebody that
only cares about the money that you
bring to the table okay so if a man
wants a beauty queen so if a man wants a
beautiful woman what does he have to do
to get a beautiful woman whatever that
beautiful woman wants which is probably
going to be money to stay beautiful and
to live that lifestyle so if that's what
you're interested in absolutely go for
it if you want to hold on a second
Martha I'm giving you the soap Buck I
want you to educate the men that are
watching right now you're saying that
I'm leading them wrong and you have a
better solution and all you're saying if
you know if you want a beautiful woman
then you have to give them money what
else what else do you have to give them
if they want to be I wouldn't know
because that's not the woman I am so I
don't know what they would want so
you're telling me that I'm doing it
wrong so what's your better
solution my better solution the guys are
waiting for
it not you yes if you want a woman who
is going to like what do you want out of
life do you want a woman who's going to
be by your side that is going to uh
raise your children and who is going to
be there in the long term then you it
doesn't matter like that's not what do
they have to do as a man to get that cuz
lots of men want a woman in their lots
of men want to have children but they're
afraid women are are
very a piece of meat you want a woman
you have a fantastic woman here on the
show by you know in the Square next to
me Brianna she's a wonderful lady who
who wants a man who's going to probably
give her that stability who's going to
make her a wife who's going to make her
a trid wife who she's going to be a
fantastic mother she she deals with
other people's children and here's the
thing the guys that are watching this
hopefully one of you guys will take her
on a date and start um a you know life
with her this is this
is you haven't given them anything to
work with to sink their teeth into
you're telling them you're saying Rich
are giving them bad advice you should be
giving them better advice I haven't
heard you give them better advice that
solves their uh sexual strategy right
they want to be with women they want to
have children they want to be in
relationships but they're finding that
it's difficult if not near impossible so
give
not I'm not here to speak to the men I
think it's more you're telling me that I
need to speak to the men differently and
provide different solutions I provide
solutions that work I make men better
men wonderful we need better men
absolutely yeah so why don't you support
my message then you're saying it's wrong
hon rich I don't the only message that I
had seen of yours prior to this and the
show where you talked about me was that
tweet so I my frame of reference is
here's a man who's telling men that
women diminish in value at 20 So based
on that context I come on this show
Beauty declines after 23 and they don't
realize it until the second time in
their
life and again if what you
want to have your children and who's
going to be a part of your life and is
going to complement the parts of your
life obviously telling her that she hits
a wall at 23 is absolutely how you're
going to get there well I wouldn't
recommend guys tell girls oh you're 24
next uh week you're going to hit the
wall so you better cash out your chips
and marry me fast like real fast now
sweetheart that's about the dumbest
thing ever like that's not the
recommendations that I make what I'm
talking about is the reality of the
world that we live in because I think
the world lies to everybody men and
women I think they lie to women Absolut
a lot yes they probably lie to women
just as much as they lie to men right
like they tell Li to women a lot more
less become l so you can become more no
they lie to women even more they are now
telling women that you can post or
they've been saying it our whole lives
you can postpone having children and at
40 somehow gonna happen are you're
beautiful at any size have you ever
heard that one of course do you think
women are beautiful at any size do you
think lizo is beautiful I personally do
not I but you're you're talking like I'm
the one saying some agreement absolutely
I said we would agree with a lot more
things than we disagree with I don't
think that lying to people in general is
the way to go I don't think that telling
men to focus on a woman's beauty is
telling them the truth if you want even
don't have to tell them that you don't
even have to tell them they do that by
osmosis they do that naturally they look
at I can tell you when I was like eight
years and the Victoria Secret catalog
would come to my house I would go look
at that immediately when the Sears
catalog would would come you'd open it
up I wasn't looking at the the toys I
wasn't looking at the hardware
department I was looking at the broad
Department okay boys do it by osmosis we
look at girls as Beauty objects we
always to tell me to do that nobody
needs to tell guy to do that I'm not
telling them anything that they don't
already know or already subscribe to I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out